anyway the game eventually got
entertaining it got very entertaining
especially if you're a buccaneers fan
but
from the panthers perspective i really
did sense
as the buccaneers took the lead and held
the lead into the second half
a desperation like a disbelief they were
apoplectic in carolina that they were
losing the game and not easily ahead and
they kept trying to will their way into
the lead i think they thought there was
like a 20-point play out there they were
going to make that all of a sudden they
were going to look up the scoreboard and
say okay this is what it was supposed to
be and they were pressing and they were
pressing and they were pressing and they
blew opportunities to put together
scoring drives because they weren't
mixing it up they weren't using
christian mccaffrey too many passes from
cam newton on a night when he was not
able to hit open receivers on a
consistent basis
cam newton looks broken he really does
and if you want to talk about thursday
night football you can go all the way
back to last year when they play against
the steelers and the panthers look like
a serious super bowl contending team cam
newton takes that hit mike he's lost
eight straight starts as the panthers
quarterback that's crazy cam newton is
not the same guy that he was for his
entire career when you're talking about
the last year for him playing football
and i don't know what it is to get right
if it's the injury if he needs to take
more time off
whatever it may be if you watch that
game you can just see it cam newton he's
not making the throws that he made when
he had an mvp season he is not the same
guy and it's it's honestly i tweeted
this last night mike but it's sad to
watch because cam newton is such an
electric football player when he is
healthy when he's got everything going
and he looks like a shell of himself in
terms of passing and the panthers won't
run him they don't run him with fourth
and one they don't they have christian
mccaffrey go to the short side just a
baffling weird spot for the carolina
panthers and i feel like they're kind of
at a crossroads here as a franchise
and and there's this strange sense of
denial as it relates to cam newton's
health ron rivera after the game was
asked by reporters about the decision to
take the ball out of cam newton's hands
not let him run the ball on a couple of
key fourth down and short last night
here's what rivera had to say when he
faced that question from reporters
well what we hope to do is you know
christian
we felt had a good opportunity to score
and so we went fake reverse
you know uh ghost action
trying to you know decom a little bit
and we had every opportunity and you
know we thought we could we could at
least get the first down unfortunately
we didn't it's cam's foot such thing no
his foot is not such we don't trust it
don't even worry about the foot the
foot's got nothing to do with it okay
what's what's the reasoning though uh
between that play that has had
statistically the fourth and one cam
sneaking statistically has had such
unprecedented success in the league but
now it is not the first option well
because we felt good about the play
scoring a touchdown
and unfortunately it didn't work
is this organizational angst big cat
about how to use cam newton and for
years people have been saying you have
to turn him into a pocket passer you
can't just assume he's indestructible
because clearly he isn't but there still
are spots where you have to take
advantage of a guy who can fall forward
and gain three yards and that's what
they should have done in that spot when
you're fourth and a half a yard game on
the line jam him up the middle i mean
that
the problem is they used to do it so
much and so excessively now they're
afraid to do it at all whether he's got
a foot problem or no foot problem
they're trying to avoid future problems
by protecting him and they're protecting
him excessively i think that's the
explanation yeah and you're right there
you know if you want to protect him in
the first second third quarter that's
fine but if you're trying to win a
football game and cam newton can't get
you a half a yard what's even the point
and i i obviously say that a little
tongue-in-cheek but seriously what is
the point if you can't get a half a yard
with cam newton up the middle
what what are we even doing here that's
it that should be an automatic for the
carolina panthers instead they don't run
them they run christian mccaffrey to the
short side a play that really makes no
sense like i the whole thing was just
very confusing to me it felt like the
panthers kind of out thought themselves
in a game that they
they should have won they were they were
in that game all all like it felt like
the entire game you were watching that
it felt like the panthers like you said
were panicking and they were down three
scores it was it was a three it was a
three point game up until three minutes
left in the game you know what i mean
like it was right there for the entire
game and the panthers they just panicked
a little bit or whatever it may be but
they out thought themselves and now
they're owen too and like i said
they have a tough schedule coming up
this is going to be
a big big season for the panthers and
what they look like as a future when
you're talking about the coach and the
quarterback because if this thing goes
even worse and starts spiraling there's
going to be some changes i would assume
you are dangerously close to talking
about another man's job didn't do it
here's the thing all or nothing the
series that will follow a team through
the course of an entire season on amazon
this most recent
installment focused on last year's
panthers and there's a spot late in the
year and i think it was actually taped
early into 2019 david tepper the new
owner of the team talking about the nfl
and how it's set up for everyone to be
eight and eight and the factors that
will drive you either above eight and
eight or below eight and eight and
obviously quarterback's one of them but
he makes a comment about gm and coach at
some point
and i remember thinking at the time
man
marty herney the gm and ron rivera the
coach are on notice because this guy
understands you can go out and buy
yourself a better gm you can buy
yourself a better coach and this guy's
rich enough to do it and the panthers
are one and nine over the last 10 games
the clock is ticking on ron rivera a guy
that i respect a guy that i admire a guy
that i banged the drum for years that
someone should have hired him to be a
head coach he used to be able to stymie
peyton manning and i'd say somebody in
the afc south hire him but have him face
peyton manning twice a year he could
constantly slow down peyton manning when
he's with the colts so yeah and he's
been the coach since 2001 he's won coach
of the year a couple of times but the
clock is ticking on ron rivera and if
this continues he's going to have to
worry about that flight home from london
and if not then he's going to have to
worry about it later in the year he's
going to have to worry about it after
the year they have got to turn this
around and they currently don't have
answers and last night norv turner
deserves a ton of the criticism for
allowing those past plays to happen at a
time when it was obvious that newton was
was lacking in confidence whatever the
reason whatever the explanation and big
cat
he is unlike any other quarterback i can
remember he is a roller coaster of
emotion and when things are going well
you see that electric smile you see the
superman thing you see the dab you see
him handing the football to the kid in
the front row all the things that make
cam newton great
but when it's not his night he just
wants to get in his car and go home and
you can't have that as the guy who was
the leader of the team it's one thing
for
defensive player running back receiver
kicker to act that way the quarterback
has to stay even keeled you can't get
too high you can't get too low because
the other guys feel it and i could feel
it coming through the tv screen last
night i could feel it too and while i
agree with you that you have to have
better body language than that i kind of
understand where cam newton is right now
as a football player because he's not
able to make the simplest of throws that
he used to be able to make and that's
got to be tremendously frustrating i
mean he you know he had some times where
he had guys wide open he had guys that
were you know even a five yard out or in
the flats and he couldn't hit them in
the right spot and that's got to be
really really hard to you know whether
it be an injury or whatever it may be
age i don't know but it's got to be
really hard to kind of come to grips
with the fact that you're not able to
make some of the same plays you've been
able to make that it may become very
easily to you your entire career
cam newton was asked last night after
the game whether he feels that he is
physically capable of running the ball
like he used to here's what he had to
say
i mean i feel okay you know um
you know but you're not gonna hear
no
type of
reasons why
tonight didn't go as planned
i have to be better no matter what
physical
condition i'm in no matter what foot
shoulder i get the job done tonight man
this and it's frustrating i wish i could
say something other than that but you
know that's that's the facts
you know the full post game press
conference is available at panthers.com
i was watching it before the show today
big cat and
um
i almost feel like he goes so far in
taking the blame it's almost passive
aggressive
and uh you know i
he he he because at some point i don't
know i think he's just look
he's wired to take the blame he's taking
the blame he but i feel like he's taking
too much of the blame for everything
because he didn't call those plays if
the quarterback's not getting it done
and you've got christian mccaffrey who
had over 200 yards from scrimmage last
week at some point you got to lean on
christian mccaffrey give him some easy
completions right if your quarterback
isn't throwing the ball accurately down
the field give him a little screen pass
give a little confidence builder give
him give him a little something that
pumps up the completion percentage why
aren't you doing that and at some point
it is on the offensive coordinator and
and he escaped last night with any
criticism
from cam newton from ron rivera from
troy aikman who wasn't going to
criticize norv turner given their
connection all those years back to the
cowboys but norv turner has a lot of
blame for what happened last night but i
told you before cam newton whether it
was uh tongue-in-cheek or not last week
said norv turner must have christopher
mccaffrey on his fantasy team with the
way he had the ball in his hand on
sunday against the rams and then you
flash forward and cam newton is the
focal point of the offense so maybe
that's why the blame wasn't put on norv
turner by cam newton because he wanted
to throw it more and norv turner allowed
him to do that my only question is cam
why don't we have a losing outfit in the
locker room i mean when you win
when you win you can wear whatever you
want when you lose
i don't know
maybe just put on a carolina panthers
hat i don't know i i
i just feel like i would be in a
different mood i'd be in a different
mood if i lose
but that's what he wore to the game i
understand but just give yourself a
backup bring a bag bring a little bag
with some sweatpants in it and if you
lose the game you can throw that on
i just
maybe that's just a personal thing but
when i'm in a bad mood when i lose i'm
not trying to dress up in any way
you you just you're just jealous that
you can't pull off the curse
i could pull that off look at this code
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports